Groundhog Day thank you for being here
let's give you some facts about where we
are today
total hospitalizations actually
basically flat technically tick down
which is probably the first tick down so
that's a good sign but basically flat so
we think we are at the apex on the
plateau the number of hospitalizations
went up flattened continuing to flatten
good sign technically the numbers down
tad statistically irrelevant but better
than being up the net change in total
hospital hospitalizations if you look at
the curve which is what we look at the
curve is down when you do the 3 day
average which is more accurate than any
one day because remember this reporting
mechanism is is new we just put it in
over during this situation so I wouldn't
bet all the chips on any one day but
when you look at three days you look at
the overall curve we think it's
indicative so the three day average is
down the net change in ICU admissions is
down again the ICU admissions I think
with the grain of salt
since hospitals are no longer what they
were and they're basically all ICU wards
intubations is a real number that's the
number of people who are being put on a
ventilator about 80% of those people
will never come off a ventilator so when
you see the intubations that is
proportionate to the number of people we
will lose and that's what we've been
watching all along people go into the
hospital
most get treated and are discharged some
are not discharged if they're intubated
about 80% of the people who are in
debated will not come off the ventilator
the number of new people go
into the hospital per day is also down
but we still have 1,600 new kovat cases
yesterday so we have 1600 people new
coming into the hospital
some being discharged and the net is
what we've been watching but it's also
interesting to note that you still have
1600 new people walking into the
hospital or who are in a hospital and
then diagnosed with Kovac so the volume
is still high and that's why the
hospitals are still working very hard we
have been watching for growth outside of
New York City Long Island was just a
Rockland that has basically been flat
they have been little hotspots here in
there Department of Health has been very
good and aggressive and jumping on those
hot spots and tamping them down tests
isolate trace and you see the numbers by
region across the state proportionately
obviously downstate New York which is
what we've been talking about but
looking for growth towards Long Island
was just a Rockland rest of the state
proportionately upstate is very very low
to everything else in the state this is
something else we're watching this is
the number of deaths in nursing homes
and the nursing homes have been an
increasing issue the nursing home issue
was flagged by the first cases we had in
the state of Washington because that is
the vulnerable population in the
vulnerable place and we've been worrying
about nursing homes from day one as we
saw in the state of Washington but you
see the percentage of loss of life is
getting higher in the nursing homes
compared to the hospital's lives lost
yesterday 778 that number is up and that
is to me the most painful number
and it has been the most painful number
every day and those New Yorkers are in
our thoughts and prayers you look at the
past few days and the number of lives
lost it's basically flat at a
devastating level of pain and grief but
it evidences everything else we're
seeing which is basically a flattening
at this level the statisticians will say
number of lives lost is a lagging
indicator which is a nice scientific
term but it doesn't mean it just is not
just terrible terrible terrible news and
nothing we can do about it although many
New Yorkers are doing everything they
can to save people's lives on a daily
basis a great personal cost to
themselves total number of deaths is
10834 what we have learned through this
process is that our actions determine
our destiny and that's actually good
news we changed the curve every
projection model White House CDC
coronavirus White House Task Force
Columbia Cornell Gates funded group
every projection had a higher rate of
infection higher rate of death CDC was
talking about over a million people CDC
was talking about projections that would
have swamped the nation's hospital
system that didn't happen why didn't it
happen because of what we did and that's
important to remember and realize we
changed the curve better way to say it
is we are changing the curve every day
we have shown that we control the virus
the virus
and control us and this is a big deal
look we could have been in a place where
we couldn't stop the spread of the virus
we could have done this whole lockdown
closed down shut down and you still
could have seen those numbers going up
that would have been a frightening place
we should take some comfort in the fact
that we have demonstrated that we can
actually control the spread of the virus
now tremendous dramatic pain to do it
shut down everything but thank God we
can control the spread can you imagine
how bad a situation it would be if we
did all of this and you still saw saw
those numbers going up you lock up your
family you protect them but somehow the
virus still infiltrated the house that
would have been frightening so there is
good news in this but there's also a
caution flag we are in some ways
artificially controlling that curve
we've taken all these extraordinary
actions and we are reducing the rate of
infection that means whatever we do
today will determine the infection rate
tomorrow it is total cause and effect so
you stop doing what you're doing or you
behave differently and you will get a
different result and that's important to
remember as we talk about reopening
everybody's anxious to reopen I get it
I'm anxious to reopen Kara Michaela went
out of the house I trust you they love
they trust me they love me they love
spending time with me but they're sort
of done with the entire experience and
that's universal people need to get back
to work the state needs an economy we
cannot sustain this for a prolonged
period of time everybody agrees but
everybody will also say how you reopen
is everything because of the fur
point which is we are now keeping down
that rate of infection and if you start
acting differently you will see a
corresponding increase in that rate of
infection and the worst scenario would
be if we did all of this we got that
number down everybody went to
extraordinary means and then we go to
reopen and we reopen too fast
or we reopen and there's unanticipated
consequences and we see that number go
up again well you're being hyper
cautious oh really
go look at other countries that went
through exactly this started to reopen
and then they saw the infection rate go
back up again so let's at least learn
from past mistakes we've laid out a way
to reopen coming up with a comprehensive
plan first that is regional in nature we
have seven states that we're working
with the virus doesn't understand state
boundaries it doesn't understand that it
needs a passport you know it defies all
of our norms so how do you put the best
minds together in a southern state area
come up with a regional strategy because
the virus can get on Amtrak the virus
can get on a plane the virus can get in
a car and drive up ninety five we're all
connected and in truth since nobody
knows where they're going and nobody's
done this before let's think together
and let's plan together if we can't come
up with a common plan let's see if we
can come up with a plan that's not
contradictory let's see if we can get to
a place where ever Connecticut does New
Jersey does is not counter to what we're
doing here in New York and that's the
point of the seven states working
together also the point is it doesn't
work unless you coordinate the
reactivation of all the systems I did
this graphically because no one got when
I went like this yesterday and I said
the gears have to
this is what I was saying I could see
Nick that you did not get what this
meant so that's a clarifier for you
personally from yesterday we also have
to be clear on who is responsible for
each element of the opening the
president said last night that he has
total authority for determining how and
when states reopened that is not an
accurate statement in my opinion now
that we know that government actually
matters and government is relevant and
that government has to be smart because
what government does is determining how
this goes it's literally determining in
many ways life and death we have to be
smart about it
the federal-state relationship is
central to our democracy this is been a
topic to discuss since our founding
fathers first decided to embark on this
entire venture right this is basic
federalism the role of the states and
the role of the federal government and
it is important that we get this right
our founding fathers understood and we
have to remember today that the balance
between the state and the federal that
magnificent balance that is articulated
in the Constitution is the essence of
our democracy
we don't have a king in this country we
didn't want a king so we have a
constitution and we elect the president
the states the colonies formed the
federal government the federal
government did not form the states it's
the colonies that ceded certain
responsibilities to a federal government
all other power remains with the states
it's basic to our Constitution and that
federal state
relationship Hamilton who in many ways
was representative of this discussion of
the balance of power state governments
possess inherent advantages which will
ever give them an influence and
ascendency ascendancy a beautiful word
over the national government and will
forever preclude the possibility of
federal encroachments on the states that
their liberties indeed can be subverted
by the federal head is repugnant to
every rule of political calculation
strong language but that was the premise
so there are laws and there are facts
even in this wild political environment
what do we do we do what we do because
we are New York tough but tough is more
complex than many people think it is
within that word tough is smart and
United and disciplined and loving they
are not they're not inconsistent to be
tough and to be loving let me make a
personal point not necessarily a factual
point the president did his briefing
last night and the president was clearly
unhappy President did a number of tweets
this morning where he's clearly unhappy
that a tweet about mutiny on the bounty
and governor's on mutineers I didn't
follow the exact meaning of the tweet
but the basic essence of the tweet was
that he was not happy with governor's
and that this was a mutiny the president
is clearly spoiling for a fight on this
issue the worst thing we can do in all
of this is start with political division
and start with partisanship
the best thing we have done throughout
this past 44 days is we've worked
together and we haven't raised political
Flags even in this hyper partisan
environment even though it's an election
year even though the politics is so
intense we said not here not in this
this is too important for anyone to play
politics it was a no politics zone right
this is just about doing the right thing
working together and that's important
and we have to stay there we're all in a
little bit of a reflective mood I'm in a
rough like this mood and everything we
do here is so important and every day is
so important and I was thinking after
the president made his comments and
looking at some of the remarks and
looking at the tweets reminded me of a
poster I saw when I was in grade school
st. Gerard Majella Queens New York
Catholic school red blazer gray pants
white shirt little clip-on tie the tie
with the hook remember the hook tie that
you had to put the hook on and then it
looked like you had a real tie which I
never understood because the hook was
harder to do you had to hook and then
you had to adjust the band which was
harder than just teaching a kid how to
just tie the tie would have been easier
but I was in grade school and there was
that poster that came from a Sandburg
poem I think suppose they gave a war and
nobody came and I was looking at the
poster and I didn't really get it
because even then I was very literal
suppose they gave a war nobody came so
I'm looking at the poster and that
priest came up behind me and said What's
Wrong Andrew I said I don't understand
that suppose they gave a war and nobody
came how could that happen then you
wouldn't have a war he said well that's
the point the point is what happened
that what would happen if people just
refused
to engage they just refused to fight and
I still didn't get it
yes and he said you know sometimes it's
better to walk away from a fight than
engage it sometimes it takes more
strength frankly to walk away from a
fight than engage it the president will
have no fight with me I will not engage
it
I've sat here every day for 44 years
asking New Yorkers to remember that this
is not about me it's about we I
understand your personally can
inconvenience I understand you're
frustrated and stressed and anxious and
you're feeling pain think about we think
about get get past yourself and think
about society and think about your
family and think about interconnection
and act responsibly for everyone else
this is no time for politics and it is
no time to fight I put my hand out in
total partnership and cooperation with
the president if he wants a fight he's
not going to get it from me period this
is going to take us working together we
have a real challenge ahead just because
those numbers are flattening is no time
to relax we're not out of the woods in
this reopening we could lose all the
progress we made in one week if we do it
wrong and we have a number of challenges
ahead we have to figure out how to do
this how do you have a public health
strategy that works with an economic
reactivation strategy nobody's done this
before how do you start to increase the
number of essential workers how do you
learn the lessons of the past how do you
start to do the massive testing that
we're going to have to do here and that
we don't have the capacity to do today
the capacity does not exist the private
sector companies that do testing we can
only get about 60
thousand tests per month that's not
enough we're going to do the antibody
testing but that's not enough either how
do we do this put together this whole
testing system and do it in a matter of
weeks
it is a real question how do we use
technology Apple and other companies are
working on using technology to do
tracking how do we do that and how do we
do it fast and how do we take all our
strengths and our collective strengths
and take this nation's collective
strength and figure out how to do those
challenges 50 years ago this week Apollo
13 gets damaged 220,000 miles from Earth
somehow they figure out how to get a
spaceship back 220,000 miles 50 years
ago that's America
okay figure out how to do testing figure
out how to use technology to do tracing
that's what we have to work on and we
have to do that together we have to do
as a government what our people have
done right sometimes political leaders
can learn best from following people who
are normally ahead of the politicians
look at how people have been selfless
and put their own agenda aside for the
common good can't their leaders be as
smart as they are the answer has to be
yes so I look forward to working with
the president in partnership and
cooperation but he has no fight here I
won't let it happen and look unless he
he suggested that we do something that
would be reckless and endanger the
health or welfare of the people of the
state then I would have no choice but
shy of that I put my hand out
to say let's do this together questions
[Music]
you screamed first you don't have the
same endurance but screaming first
matters you're talking right now about
making peace with Donald Trump with the
president and yet you went on television
four times this morning and we're asked
about it and opined about it repeatedly
you called him a king you said that his
press briefings were like a comedy
sketch why didn't you just say no
comment
if you're trying to make peace with him
no the first point is he does not have
total authority I mean I'm a governor of
a state the statement that the he has
total authority over the states and the
nation cannot go uncorrected I mean it's
just a factual statement that is
factually wrong Tenth Amendment to the
Constitution it's a whole body of case
law I mean there are many things you can
debate in the Constitution because
they're ambiguous this is not one of
those things that is ambiguous so that
that statement cannot stand and it's not
only violative of the Constitution its
violence they're the very concept of
democracy I mean this was the first
battle do we want a king or do we want a
president and we opted for a president
so that statement cannot stand period
attacks you know calling him a king
saying that it's like a comedy sketch
saying it is his Proclamation is that he
would be king that's what a king is a
king has total authority that statement
cannot stand the whole mutiny on the
bounty the governors are mutineers
whatever that means and whatever the
rest of the theory was I'm not going to
fight I'm not going to get into that
fight look I bent over backwards
he took her who said a nasty comment
about what it was but
right I worked very hard to be in
partnership with the federal government
this past month I worked very hard to
stay away from politics and he is right
I did call and say I need federal
assistance I did call and say I need
possible overflow beds that he is right
that he did move very quickly to get us
Javits and the US and his comfort and I
said that repeatedly and I praised him
for his actions and he was right there
too the federal government has a very
important role I was a cabinet secretary
I did it for eight years I know how key
the federal government is frankly I know
how powerful they actually could be in
being of assistance and I don't even
think they were as powerful as they
could be and the federal government has
tremendous tremendous capacity that we
need now so yes he's right on all of
that he's right that we asked for
cooperation and assistance and he's
right that he delivered and I've said
that all along but this mutineers and it
can't exist
I don't have anything specific to talk
to him about today there's no action
item for us to talk about be my pleasure
to speak with him but we don't have
anything that is do we have anything
pending no I did speak to the White
House this morning about a hospital
matter but other than that we don't have
anything immediate no we haven't had
that conversation and this is a shift in
federal position which is also fine by
the way we're entering a new phase the
quote-unquote reopening phase on the
first phase which was the closed down
phase the president took a different
tact the president did not close down
the economy he did do the travel ban
with China and he was right on the
travel ban with China the closed down of
the economy was left to the governors
and I closed down New York Governor
Pritzker closed down Illinois Governor
Lamont closed down Connecticut did at
different times different ways but he he
left that responsibility of closing down
of the economy to the governor's you get
to the reopening of the economy well the
governor's closed it down wouldn't the
governor's reopen it president says no I
have a different model that I'm
envisioning that's okay too but it's a
shift but it's okay
but then what is that model and let's
talk about who does what which is the
intelligent conversation we have to have
how do we do this testing how does that
come up the scale
I can't do it how do we do this
technology and I understand he's right
it raises constitutional questions and
do you really want that cellphone in
your pocket to be a tracking device
right okay so let's talk through how we
do that how do we disinfect a public
transit system that has to be understood
how do we have masks for every New
Yorker how do we do that how do we get
10 20 million masks so we have that
added protection how do we get gloves
how do we make sure god forbid there's a
second wave where there's another uptick
that we have the medical equipment we
need if that we just went through this
horrendous hurry-up exercise by the way
where's the funding for states to help
do this I'm broke
there's no fancy way to say that we have
a ten billion dollar deficit well the
state should do this and do this and do
this and do this I don't have two
nickels to rub together and the past
federal legislation didn't give us
anything the only thing you gave the
states was some Medicaid money doesn't
give us anything to do any of this they
talked about it in the next legislation
if there is one but that's the
intelligent conversation to have
I have always had an open line of
communication with him I mean there been
times in the past when he hasn't been
happy with me and I haven't been through
throwing bouquets to him but we've
always communicated and I'm sure we'll
communicate now but I just want to make
my position clear I am NOT going to
fight with him I don't want this is no
time for any division with between the
federal government and the state
governments and the governor's who I
work with Democrats we Republican
governor in Massachusetts it's not a
political conspiracy governor Baker's a
Republican this is not about democratic
or republican it's just not this is
about New York 2,000 lives lost these
were not 10,000 Democrats at 10,000
Republicans
10,000 people period forget the don
politics everyone's tired with put out
the nursing home death data by county
yesterday and as you could see some of
them had one case what we're worried
about is personal privacy protection
working with the Department of Health
there's more than there's about 600
nursing homes in a state
this goes for hospitals as well there's
some very small hospitals where they
report out one or two deaths a day we
just want to go through the data and
make sure we're not really seeing any
potential personal information and as
soon as that's done that will be made
available for people so that's why we
put the aggregate numbers out by county
that's what we're going through
nursing home so it's hard to tell but
you know we're seeing issues like I
talked about yesterday in
hospitalizations in different parts of
state we look at we look at total beds
being used we look at deaths we look at
all of that in certain downstate parts
of the region New York City and the
outer boroughs and Nassau County we have
seen increased cases but that has gone
across the board whether it be
hospitalizations or nursing homes as
well so that's now part of the County
data that you do see but so one is that
true 60,000 a month but then mayor de
Blasio said that they're going to start
being able to do a hundred thousand
tests a week fifty homegrown 50,000
homegrown efforts fifty thousand
purchased from an Indiana company so how
does that coordinate with state efforts
and again is that sixty thousand
capacity crowd the signed on the dotted
line what's happening with the testing
companies is the same thing that
happened with medical equipment PPE and
ventilators there are just a handful of
companies that produce the private tests
and they're all private tests by the way
a handful companies that do it and now
every state is going to those companies
to buy the tests I've spoken to the head
of the several companies myself and they
have a limited production and now they
have to allocate it to 50 states and
we're again in a bidding war competition
with other states I would say the
federal government you take that piece
don't replicate the 50 state pandemonium
you won't talk about an increased
federal role let FEMA do the testing
FEMA should have in my opinion done all
the purchasing of the medical equipment
and they should have allocated it why am
I now competing for private testing
capacity in private tests
machines with Illinois in California I
want to get out of the eBay competition
business for vital medical equipment and
now vital testing I would say that the
president you take it
god bless you because you have different
bids and different promises from
companies to different governments all
across the country
like I bought 17,000 ventilators and
then I didn't get we only got about
3,000 2500 the same thing is going to
happen with the testing that's what well
they're told that from a company do I
believe we're gonna see those numbers
actually produced no because I think the
same thing is going to happen that we
just went through for the past month
where those companies who can get
oversubscribed they're then going to bid
up the price and it's gonna go to the
highest bidder we learned this lesson I
saw this movie I just lived it for the
past month it costs taxpayers tremendous
amounts of money private companies got
very rich you want to talk about going
to a new phase with a different model
let's inform it from the past model tell
FEMA you buy all the tests for the
country allocate them by need this is
where the cases are New York you're X
percent of the cases Illinois you're y %
of the cases Massachusetts you're z
percent of the cases the federal
government is going to buy them and then
the federal government is going to
allocate them not this you know let's
let's give each government or level of
government functions that they perform
best and one of the really painful
lessons was all this crazy competing by
states and cities for medical equipment
we're going to do that again I makes no
sense
the serological tests and what's the
plan if those can't get scaled up in the
way what is the Yak accuracy system it
ferries there are many different tests
there we're looking at the tests that
haven't you know over 95% accuracy we
were working to scale this up both by
our public lab which is our state lab
the private sector labs that are out
there we're looking at those as well as
the hospitals which have labs as well we
are looking at that for example our
state lab the tests that we've developed
is basically six standard deviations out
which basically means that you're really
way up there over the 99% accuracy if
not higher you are right there are
different private-sector tests with
different accuracy rates and that's one
of the other complications go by tests
or hose test which tests what level of
accuracy and that I think it's something
we have to figure out one way or the
other but I would say that's something
the federal government should take the
state we are will be by next week at
2000 tests that we will be able to do
per week right at that point no sorry a
2,000 tests per day next week but that's
that part but we're also working with
some of the private sector companies to
be able to get in the tens of thousands
of tests as well as the hospital several
hospitals have developed tests there are
different ways to do these tests you
could do as a blood test we are looking
at a finger stick test as well where you
just do a little blood spot and there's
technology for that as well follow-up
wonderful second look you could have a
whole symposium on testing there are two
types of tests the antibody test and the
diagnostic test the antibody tests State
Health Department as a test and you're
right it's
limited capacity let's say they can do
you said 2,000 a day so let's say 14,000
a week
what is 40,000 a week going to do for
you and by the way the whole anti what
can the antibody population really be in
the scope of things right antibody
population people who had the illness
and have recovered okay that's important
to know and we're very aggressive on the
antibody testing but how many people are
going to test positive right what
percent of the population at this point
do you think had the corona virus what
could a number be twenty percent ten
percent okay you want to find that ten
percent twenty percent but then that's
not enough to restart and get back to
normalcy that diagnostic test is going
to be key and now think of the volume on
that diagnostic test
we're 19 million people how many
diagnostic tests do you want to buy for
19 million people and then multiply that
by the nation look at the need and I'm
telling you you literally have a handful
of private sector companies that do this
now well how do you scale that up I
don't know how did you get a rocketship
220,000 miles back from the moon 50
years ago but if you could figure that
out you can figure this out and if the
federal government wants to know a
valuable role this is going to be a key
element to all of this no you would
never get if you if you said that was
the prerequisite you'd be closed ad
infinitum but you want testing capacity
as a tool where businesses can use it as
a tool you want temperature taking right
you open up a business they're going to
say I want to take everybody's
temperature as they walk in the door all
right how do you take the temperature of
500 people walking into a business you
know just think of all the things you
have to do and then divide it between
the Feder
government than the state government we
have to clean all the buses and all the
trains we want to clean all the park
benches we want to have a disinfectant
solution where we have a cleaning
protocol that we've never had before we
want the technology to do the tracing
once we find the person who is positive
and we can retrace them through the
technology how do we balance that with
individual liberties there's a lot to do
here and let's the states cannot do this
on the road I'm not shy about capacity
I'm very proud of what we do in the
state government when I tell you I can't
do something it's the first time you've
heard me say that since I've been
governor but I'm telling you we can't do
this so why is it that we're seeing
hundreds of people dying in nursing
homes from cozy-like was there lakhs you
can't because you cannot stop it you
cannot stop it
look we have no visitors going to a
nursing home you want to hear talk about
a harsh policy no visitors must be close
to a month you're in a nursing home you
can't get visitors this staff has to be
checked when they come in every day but
by the way taking somebody's temperature
that's not a foolproof mechanism and any
one of those staff members could be
walking in with a spark in their pocket
to to torture the metaphor and that
population is so vulnerable it just
takes one staff member who didn't have a
temperature but did have the virus to
walk in and now you're going to have a
serious problem you want to comment on
that
point is that the government just raised
is that the crux of all this that their
individuals with multi organ systems
many other problems heart problems
diabetes asthma respiratory problems
their immune system is just not as good
or as robust and so they get sick with
whether it's this or the flu and they
end up in the hospital many of the
patients that you have mentioned that's
sick and died a lot of those they were
transferred to the hospital but ninety
five years of age with multiple medical
problems it's a it's a tough battle for
them to sever what you've learned is
you've learned your strengths and your
weakness right you've learned that you
can control the virus and that's a
powerful lesson because we weren't
always sure that we could right but
you've also learned your weakness you
cannot hermetically seal society you
can't hermetically seal a nursing home
you can't put it in a bubble and say I
can protect these vulnerable people you
can't you can't isolation
no visitors every staff member has to be
checked an ember one ember finds its way
in and then it is fire through dry grass
the city of Rochester I want to try to
get everybody wants to ask a question to
do it I also need visual aids but in the
city of Rochester yesterday there was a
hundred person vigil after a shooting
there and it was apparently okayed by
the mayor is it appropriate to hold
large gatherings like that one videos
online show that people were not likely
social distancing during this well I
don't know these specifics and I don't
want to comment on the specifics but we
spent a lot of time not only saying
there should be no large gatherings we
even said no large gatherings during
religious holidays which a lot of people
are unhappy about but look that was the
first you know at least learned the
lesson right learn the lesson of New
Rochelle New Rochelle muy New Rochelle
Westchester oh that's New York City
no it
not it's not a dense urban environment
it's in a suburban community and that
was one person in religious gatherings
that could happen anywhere in the
country at any given time so we learned
that lesson and we've been advocating
that I mean I I couldn't be more clear
on who didn't ask who do this it takes
two to tango
it takes two to get into a fight takes
two people to get into a litigation I am
NOT interested in fighting with the
president and I can't be more clear in
that I'm not gonna allow anything bad to
happen to the people I represent right I
see my job very clearly I get hired by
the people of the state of New York to
fight for them and to protect them I'm
trained as a lawyer slash advocate grew
up at the kitchen table it's Mario Cuomo
a natural-born lawyer slash advocate I
will fight with all my might to protect
New Yorkers but I don't think it comes
to that I do not want to fight with the
president he is wrong on the law I don't
think this is a legal issue this is no
time you don't even have the luxury for
the argument and there's too much to do
for everyone it's just too much to do I
can't do it he can't do it I'm not even
sure how quickly we can do it together
so what's the favor
come up with a new question fast no got
me a better question than that crime
would be the argument Constitution I
call Alexander Hamilton thank you guys
you